alors on se repasse l'ouverture
tranquillou
ok
à ce moment là pour pas laisser 5 voilà
et ça ça rentre dans une grue
donc il a pris il y a trois attaques le
pion et il a fait ses 5 alors je crois
et bon à vérifier mais qui tu peux jouer
C3 avec les Noirs aussi pour le filer
comme ça baisser faire ses 5 maintenant
ça dépend
lui il a choisi ces cinq directs donc
structure plus symétrique mais ou
peut-être quelques temps d'avance
peut-être côté blanc on va avoir en tout
cas les carreaux qui est très préparé
hein regardez il a dépensé que 15
secondes alors il y a le rajout de trois
secondes et c'est Magnus qui réfléchit
en premier
c'est un peu à mon avis un peu échaudé
il avait perdu contre kaway dernière
fois en speechasse est-ce que il Carlos
serait pas plus fort maintenant que que
Magnus Fab bon franchement
il avait été assez impérial et le C5 qui
pose problème alors attention sur des
Français 5 il a encore le temps de faire
ces trois éventuellement pour détruire
la structure et il a joué du coup
cavalier prend ces quatre magnussy ne
laisse pas oui c'est le plus logique
hein la poussée du pion donc là est-ce
qu'il va prendre en décaps maintenant et
laisser les chevaux arriver là où la
dame ou la dame ouais qui pourrait
donner une position intéressante à
Magnus qui serait quand même en avance
sur le développement il fait fou aussi
ce cavalier ça donc ça a l'air d'être la
prépa ça tape maintenant en B7 mais les
Noirs pourraient se décaler par un dam
C8 ou fous des 5 s'arrête les deux coups
des cinq alors la question c'est d'essai
foutran G2 éventuellement de me prendre
vite reprendre les deux est-ce que tu
récupères le pion c'est toute la
question c'est si tu fais rien pendant
deux coups je te fais fouiller trois
tours c'est un et merci au revoir
et la partie est terminée
en fait c'est pas risqué
là maintenant il y a une réflexion côté
blanc pour savoir est-ce qu'on vient
échanger en D8 ou pas alors probablement
non parce que placer la tour sur la
colonne ouverte ça paraît pas logique
mais les échecs comme tu disais c'est un
jeu de précision de toute façon aux
échecs tu es jamais sûr après non non
mais tu sais de décider en ton ami
conscience d'ailleurs il a pris
rendez-vous s'enlève une des pièces il
faut que tu aurais pu attaquer ses 5
exact
elle est chiante des découvertes des
machins il a préféré la supprimer
concéder cette colonne il se dit
peut-être bon on s'en fiche un peu façon
l'important c'est le Punto voilà et bon
le truc comme je dis ce qu'il y a de
rassure avec les Blancs c'est au pire tu
le perds égales je le sens dans le très
dur là
bah c'est pas grave
il est en train de calculer là
qui est protégé par le cavalier derrière
cavalier prend sur mon front
cavalier prend tour des deux très
dangereux pour les Noirs parce que
même pas sûr qu'il a pas choisi de faire
B4 il a choisi de faire Flo 3 qui était
la deuxième option on n'a pas eu le
temps de regarder
à 6 ah ouais mais il doit être très
content attends il faut regarder car oui
bon là ça ouais là ça va
Sixx bify
qui a réussi pas à défendre son pion
correctement peut-être il doit quand
même tenter B4 et tour à B1 il peut
faire bien
comme position c'est toujours que les
Blancs qui peuvent être mieux ici sur
une dernière vérification il prend B4
probablement ou cavalier C2 et là
pourquoi pas cavalier 6 d'ailleurs il
fait à 5 alors à 5 à 3 il va avoir la
même position avec le pion A5 est-ce que
ça le favorise probablement oui un Fab
ah il fait qui est ici ok donc oui bon
c'est le fameux truc où le pion B7
passant en C6 est-ce qu'on est si
content
c'est toujours l'histoire de daffaire la
case B6 et puis le pion A5 est quand
même à la tour à 8 est attaché à sa
défense
surtout qu'il a calculé il y a longtemps
avantages mais il faut qu'il ait le 5
qui est pas évident visuellement
parce que si tu l'as pas mal ouais voilà
tu prends 3 tours c'est vite c'est quoi
la comprendre
qui traînent mais des trucs de merde
comme ça direct
là le premier qui est descend quand on
là Torcé 8 il a torté un il a pas du
tout
il a la finale ça a joué hyper vite mais
pas mal comme ça
va mais il a ouais mais bon là c'est
chaud c'est pas compliqué tout à l'heure
mais bon c'est double fourchette non
plus parce que sinon il aurait fait F ou
il préfère ça un roi actif comme ça
ouais mais il est il est il est
forteresse pour l'instant
F3 ça paraît logique appelle une voie
lactée
c'est des ciseaux qui est logique aussi
contrôle la case au 4 bon son idée ça
aurait fait le 4 et déjà finir le roi
donc on peut pas échanger
qui est ici s'il a fait F5 il a pas
voulu voir
mais là il veut regarder trois rois F7
roi C3 roi E6 roi B4 3D 5 et qui est b2n
je pense ça gagne assez facile pour les
blancs mais bon après c'est Hikaru au
noir quand même
deux faire cavalier
4 et du coup tu ramènerai le roi pour
je suis d'accord tu attends
en C6 en fait et essayer de bloquer le
truc ça demande des efforts mais je
pense c'est ce qu'il veut faire regarde
Magnus il fait ce qu'il fait ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire et on fait aussi je pense
que la seule manière de parler à gagner
c'est de trop mal au temps et de se
prendre un piège et c'est ce qu'il est
en train de faire roi des deux
[Musique]
il est mal
qui a une idée
comme intéressant et c'est jouer et oui
et regarde ça quand même ça se dandine
un petit peu alors pourquoi tu veux
mettre le cavalier en C2 donc là on
reprend A4 l'idée clairement à mon avis
c'est roi c'est toi
qui est bien
pour prendre la case mais attention il
peut y avoir après qui c'est 5 mais tu
peux faire
[Musique]
24 secondes là il recommence à prendre
confiance le streamer
qu'est-ce qu'il a un coup d'attendre
avec des pions de l'autre côté je pense
il va faire F4 c'est logique c'est le
coup numéro 1 l'ordi une nouvelle fois
vous avez plus de solutions
ça aurait été mon coup logique aussi
j'aurais pu hésiter avec le 4 kc5
j'aurais eu peur de kbk4 ah il repart
avec le roi vers ah de toute façon tu as
pas le choix non mais c'est pas con
peinture il protège le pion et
maintenant il va les faire chier qu'il
va aller au 4 et ses trois qui avaient
lieu de qu'est-ce qu'il est fort et Caro
dans ses positions plus de 10 plus que 9
et c'est peut-être Ikaru qui va jouer le
gars Fab attention non mais vraiment
attention minus c'est peut-être encore
dominé par un joueur finalement
peut-être plus fort que lui il tombe sur
du lourd aujourd'hui c'est quasiment du
jeu à trois résultats
avec ton cavalier pour aller en prendre
un au prix de A4 tu auras déjà un peu
avancé dans ta course ouais c'est 4
c'est un aveu de faiblesse Fab le roi
quitte le contact du pion
j'ai 5 il envoie le contre jeu attention
Magnus il a plus qu'une seconde la
moindre déco le problème serveur chescom
attention quand même les erreurs 505 ça
peut arriver mais faire attention ma
tort j'ai eu des petits lacs d'une
demi-heure une seconde sur chascom
attention
[Musique]
du du H5 tout à l'heure ça a pas été
joué par hasard évidemment et peut-être
faire un F4 échec il fait G4 c'est un
coup tellement maximaliste il se bloque
le cavalier mais tellement vite mais je
pense qu'il veut jouer avec F4 après
hein il joue avec E4 et il se retrouve
la casse qui est G4 échec
c'est hyper bizarre ce qu'il a fait mais
bon
bah s'éloigner qui
problème
[Musique]
et avoir cavalier F5 et sacrifier et
sacrifié il a l'air dégoûté à l'écran
roi B5 va faire cavalier B3
là il faut trouver comment faire
H4 et F5 H5 et G3 ça c'est nul direct
mais c'est pas facile Fab
issue il trouve pas
il panique
ah c'est la panique côté Hikaru ici
la perd pas en fait
c'est pas fait encore
ça s'est vu il a explosé
le chaos tu vois on n'a pas besoin de
chaise boxing pour mettre des joueurs KO
ici
allez il faut revenir faut courir mais
pas moi
il faut choisir la bonne case qui est
des si c'est bien joué il y a pas roi F6
il va pouvoir venir en E4 il s'accrocher
alors attention c'est pas encore
complètement fait Fab maintenant
il a envie quelle partie en tout cas
pleine de rebondissements
il va revenir
ouais
cavalier c'est 4
cavaliers
il le fait
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué défense
incroyable du carreaux mais
c'est pas passé loin alors ça commence
alors on va voir ce que je veux jouer
en fait
les conseils du coach quand même il fait
la même chose
c'est bon je vais bien jouer les trucs
à lui tout seul
YouTube
et oui et oui ça rigole que américain je
fais un devoir regarder
à 40 grands regarde les têtes qui fait
non mais c'est ouais
et donc cette vente là c'est pas con que
c'est toi
tu as des cinq aussi
et aussi ce qui est tombé tempo bon en
gros c'est très souple côté noir tu peux
jouer avec avec des 5 avec ses 5 avec E5
mais bon on te fait 6 mois mais tu veux
toujours faire des six et prépare le 5
plus tard
j'ai exactement la tête de Michao et son
petit regard de loin
si tu donnes à manger
une pièce bon c'est assez rusé quand
même
mais peut-être qu'il y a eu 7 et là tu
es en carapace totale quoi
et après
j'aurais pas pensé au coup normalement
tout ce qui est pire que moderne machin
en fait si tu prends pas le truc à la
gorge comme ça va dans tous les sens
c'est pas si il va jouer des seins que
5c 5 rien peut-être dans 10 coups on
verra peut-être F5 peut-être
t'as pas de lisibilité en fait les noirs
peuvent s'adapter
hyper facilement à ce que tu fais
une inverse pas forcément vrai bon c'est
un côté plus simple mais là le fait
d'avoir la paire de fou je préfère les
Noirs
honnêtement façon de parler c'est juste
que ils sont évidemment mieux mais après
oui c'est plus difficile de dire à quel
point ils le sont
aussi à faire des cinq quatre essayer de
faire
plutôt avec les Blancs parce que en fait
pourquoi je dis je sais pas mais
tu fais rien bon t'as pas une histoire
quand même t'as pas de faire des preuves
[Musique]
ou quoi il prend
un choix un peu dégoûté quoi
sur le Caval mais pourquoi pas
il va
probablement faire F5 et tu as tous les
plans possible donc à venir pour la case
V3
tu as G5 F4 rouleaux compresseur j'ai 5
h 5 H4 peu importe quoi enfin tu avances
toutes ces cases noires
mais je sais pas il y a beaucoup quoi il
sert à rien
il défend le pion maintenant
enlever le cahier des 5 qui a pièce
forte des blancs et il vient aussi se
replacer le pion
ça donne de la force au fuget vous la
Colona tu feras C5 après si tu es avec
les noirs pour c'est la partie
d'ailleurs prises et tour des deux mais
IKO
au moins
mais il sait faire le dos rond
c'est son énorme point fort
c'est 5 et 5 qui vient prendre le
contrôle de la case D4 il a fait X3
est-ce qu'il peut avoir quelque chose
après c'est son énorme point fort il
réussit à jouer sans trop de plans comme
ça et refaire du coup par coup après
ouais un peu comme les ordit
[Musique]
à cause de fou des 7
mais bon c'est bon bizarre
au détriment un peu des pions bizarres
j'ai l'impression qu'il veut faire son
niveau à deux
pour blinder sa colonne des soit il veut
se mettre en B1 et essayer de faire un
truc contre
B a c'est vraiment ouais
il devait avoir une idée sur F5 qu'on a
pas vu tu peux checker
dans certaines lignes
[Musique]
ok ça part en ligne
un truc vraiment simple après nous on se
fait moi non plus hein
c'était pas facile à comprendre c'est
que les coussins en chaîne c'est dur
5 ouais bon bien joué évidemment il veut
profiter du fait que le fou soit parti
de l'autre côté enfin il est pas encore
complètement parti mais s'ils vendait ça
en tout cas ça sera le cas pour aller
ouvrir la loi la question c'est est-ce
que tu calmes un H4 est-ce que tu fais
tout a à deux et tu t'enlèves du
vis-à-vis
donc on va voir si réussi il a fait H4
ça réfléchit fort
ça fait peur mais bon quand tu vas faire
j'ai 5 qui va prendre tu vas prendre il
va faire G4 il aura dame G4 quand même
toujours
enfin faut qu'il s'organise pour pas
pour rien perdre mais il peut peut-être
la tenir tu peux t'énerver là regarde il
reprend confiance
qui craque une nouvelle fois il est mais
là
qui favorit de la partie au vu du
scénario ça me fait penser à ce que
m'expliquer mon coach muretas c'est le
dernier qui met les coups qui a donc
aujourd'hui
8 là c'est c'est un peu la panique il y
a très concentré évidemment pour pas
saccager tout le travail défensif fait
jusque là mais il faut acheter un
premier regard ça y est là les coups là
et quand il a le fil là il y a eu le
coup de panique à un moment donné il a
ouh ah bah oui
regarde plus qu'une 34 pour Magnus moins
bien autant maintenant langage corporel
du carreau maintenant très positif et
Magnus aux abois en plus ça a été
prémouv
non mais il lui met tous les tous les
fondamentaux
et ça prémouvent absolument tous les
coups
qui ont l'initiative du jeu
pas simple à jouer encore la partie pas
et pas faite
je sais pas ce qu'il veut
et ça peut aller dans tous les sens
bien joué il vient un peu toucher ce
cavalier
de nouveau
tension sinon on peut faire c'est quand
même une option il va pas le faire je
pense
mais ce serait pas perdant pour pour les
noirs
pour B8 ah il va tout échanger OK
il veut passer devant F5
et le roi tu le mets où en deux à droite
à gauche
et c'est nul signé femme toujours sympa
d'avoir des classico et c'est reparti
pour notre classico femme avec une Nimzo
alors ça a peut-être être une ragosine
est-ce que le cavalier va venir en C3
[Musique]
et tu dois faire des 5 et en gros tu as
juste un grand bidame gratuit mais bon
je sais pas si c'est grave ou pas mais
c'est bien ce que je pensais ça c'est la
vente vintolinch on a fait une vidéo
avec Mathieu sur cette vidéo la vidéo la
variante vintoline charmentée par
vintolinch OK et alors c'était ça
hyper intéressant
pas du tout logique parce que tu te
retrouves à décaler un pion à doubler un
pion là-bas en B4 mais tu contrôles les
cases
[Musique]
c'est pas c'est pas logique
mais tu trouves cette logique mais une
vidéo sur la chaîne faite avec Mathieu
ou c'était une partie d'une tenue
justement
très très belle partie mais ouais c'est
pas logique d'échanger un pion central
qui contrôle le centre de base contre un
pion a qui contrôle qu'une case c'est
incroyable à l'époque d'avoir eu cette
idée de de ressentir que c'était bon
très anti-positionnel mais très
intéressantes vous qu'à bien jouer de la
part du carreau de sortir cette arme un
peu de la botte il suit les bonnes
chaînes
on voit une autre utilité en éliminant
le pion à deux il s'est donné cette
tasse B4 pour le cavalier qui n'est plus
contrôlé et tu contrôles les cases les
cases blanches en fait
centrale après encore qui est B5 etc
c'est loin d'être fait mais là tu peux
même te permettre d'ici sinon bêtement
pas évident à jouer on me donne ça me
choque pas moi
écoute
l'ordi je sais pas
on va voir
très puissant pour eux de réfléchir
comme ça alors oui et non enfin en fait
oui ça te fatigue mais ils ont
l'habitude donc tu finis pas la journée
en pleine forme normalement mais c'est
ils ont l'habitude de répéter ces
efforts quoi tiens tu vois là l'idée on
peut on peut la retrouver un peu dans
cette variante là
du coup t'as pas cavalier des trois qui
aurait pu être fort parce qu'il y a
s'il a vraiment rien et qui jette les
blancs la poubelle comme ça quoi
si tu peux faire des preuves aussi tu
vois enfin on va pas regarder c'est
particulièrement et c'est
c'est peut-être une option aussi
alors que moi je préfère
être ouvert je sais pas je pense pouvoir
faire des ruptures des B5 des machins je
suis content quoi
marrant mais oui je pense que c'est
équivalent non mais là au moins il est
pas en train de galérer à défendre un
truc
au bord du gouffre
c'est le même c'est la même chose c'est
ça qu'en fait tu peux vraiment là moi je
me serais pris une fois tu as joué une
fois le truc tu connais et tu fais un
petit G6 ou pas
surtout dans la finale dans l'autre cas
tous ces deux
c'est 5 donc c'est ça en vrai dans les
varandes c'est quand on échange tout le
problème c'est qu'il y a un match du
couloir on est passé un peu vite pour
rester sur le direct de toute façon la
tour à vide ça fait la 8e rangée ouais
et ben très bien ok mais
résultat logique
c'est normal ça finit sur nul comme ça
alors est-ce que ça peut être une
berlinoise et drôle et
il va faire je sais pas dans sa tête
mais
mais c'est plus une bonne année qui fait
plus trop
c'est une bonne illustration
si regarde tu as une idée c'est de faire
ton H4 dégager la dame et où des fois
dans mes formes ça c'est autre chose
avec le pion des 4 là le bon coup des
Noirs c'est G5 parce que sur Full prend
F5 double attaque mais là il y a pas de
double attaque
où on explique ça ouais alors après on
avait montré surtout la partie de
Marshall afin qu'elle est capable en cas
Marshall ou ça a été joué la première
fois à très haut niveau ou pas ou
Marshall en fait faisait pas 6 pour
défendre le cavalier mais repartait vers
fcg4
et les deux hier on fait 10 minutes
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y en a qui va
prendre le lien
à mon avis tu descends plus
ça fait très longtemps que personne
n'est rentré dans le
Caro qui essaye quand même un truc si tu
veux vraiment l'annuler
vraiment pas faire
il fait 13h non Tati fait une fois
j'ai pressenti quand même là ça va jouer
à l'armée
aux enchères etc etc alors qu'il y a
quoi c'est Caro qui a les blancs 15
minutes contre 9
c'est quand même c'est beau joueur
donc Kiko obligation de gagner aussi à
noter que pour cette Armageddon il y a
plus le rajout de temps
aujourd'hui non non il y a pas d'erreur
il y a pas de rajout il y a pas les
trois secondes
et Magnus donc qui joue comme une
anglaise pour le moment
ça va faire pour appeler blanc
aussi avec ces quatre j'imagine encore
instantanément
et à 4
c'est juste une instinienne
il va partir vers C4 pour attaquer le
pion le 5
normalement pour toucher le fou
j'ai 4 j'ai 3 et tu repars tu repars en
H5 G6
[Musique]
repars à la maison il fait froid H5
il est tout sourire je crois qu'il est
heureux
pas de rajout de temps dans cette
armagidon donc là contrairement aux
parties qu'on suit toute la journée si
tu commences à t'approcher des deux
trois minutes tu peux commencer dans en
danger car vous qui lui conserve son
temps qui ne se réduit pas comme peau de
chagrin alors après si il regarde 5
intermédiaires ou quoi non et là tu as
peut-être 5 puis on prend F5 genre tu me
le mets en exercice tu le mets en partie
genre E-5 puis on prend et F5 parce que
dans les Écossais c'était un peu ces
idées là
de laisser le pion des fois E5 et puis
si tu prends la casse cavalier
pour revenir vers g3f5 c'est aussi très
bien joué
maintenant est très très élégant
mais même là je regarde encore en fait 5
puis on prend F5 si j'échange ma charge
reviens avec le fou mais bon là ça
marche moins bien
[Musique]
en fait tu bloques tellement les pièces
à faire domino tour mais bon
c'est une question de goût vers c'est
toujours le mail de leur dire 5
d'ailleurs il prend même pas sur E5 il
fait fou et 7
allez commence par roi H1 pourquoi ben
de toute façon c'était un coup qu'on
avait dans le plan alors ouais mais
c'est une concession
échanges une bonne pièce pourquoi une
bonne pièce que regarder les pions sont
sur case noir donc le foot de cases
blanches rayonne de mille feux il
rayonne un peu dans les pions adverse
mais il est rayonnants ce fout là c'est
un fou qui normalement est derrière la
structure mais bon une fois qu'il en H3
il est quand même déjà nettement mieux
que on connaît pas de la partie
mais en soi oui normalement avec les
Blancs crachent pas sur cet échange
décidé mais il s'est fait fixer les
pions sur noir avec son foot case noir
la série de coups semble plutôt en
faveur de Magnus quand même ouais ouais
de toute façon on sentait
pas H4 on partirait vers H5 avec le
cavalier espion nous servent quelque
part même de bouclier attention une dame
des cinq et du coup pour G6 c'est très
logique pour venir prendre les devants
sur cette colonne voilà la partie reste
très équilibrée Magnus qui a un petit
avantage de par le fait que il ait le
droit de faire nul des 40 le 2 juin
on va vous le montrer donc ça serait la
variante qui gagnerait mais on peut pas
faire tourner H2 pour cacher
contrôle il est encore F4 ouais donc
c'est cavalier prend E5 champions
mais il met en place quand même le setup
problèmes
et du coup il fait de la F3 qui est
procédé en train de craquer
pour dame F3 ça peut pas aller ah non
le fait de pas avoir joué enfin en tout
cas ça avait l'air de donner une
position vraiment qui joue qui se jouait
facile et vraiment dame C6 bien joué
Hikaru écureuil
il sait qu'il est obligé d'échanger les
dames
et il sait qu'il est obligé de faire ça
alors excellent défenseur donc s'il
devait simplement faire nul il pourrait
peut-être il sera encore en confiance
mais là il est obligé de gagner il a
encore une petite chance
Ikao
les cavaliers
donc assistant B6 c'est bien joué
d'avoir décalé le pion lui déjà
comprennent en six
ce qu'on perdra un tempo pour revenir en
7e le roi arrivant F3 et ça peut jouer
plus le temps
descend puis on peut être sous pression
donc il fait à 5
fou maintenant
la dernière séquence de coût est quand
même de nouveau plutôt en faveur du
carreaux même s'il reste derrière
évidemment des trois attention se font
en C3 ça peut faire des accidents
peut-être
il va regarder calculer à mon avis un
petit coup franc à 5 est-ce que il aura
le temps x 8 c'est 3 tu vois tu reprends
à 4 si c'est chèque ce genre de choses
ou toi tu veux prendre Jessie c'est
qu'on ça va amener droit aussi et
commencer à courir c'est ce qui fait
alors est-ce que des G5 peuvent être
intéressants pour essayer tout disloquer
peut-être pas tout de suite mais roi G7
3 F3 on a quoi de moi on a deux pions de
moins mais il y en a un deux trois qui
peuvent tomber rapidement on va tous
tomber en même temps malheureusement
mais bon ils peuvent tomber femme mais
surtout en fait on peut faire tomber
rapidement des trois et A5 ce qui nous
donner virtuellement un pion de plus
j'ai 7 je suppose roi F3 mais attention
la tour va pouvoir se décaler vers des 4
c'est ce qui caroue semble venir de voir
ses 6 d'abord tourner 8 quand même
c'est toujours très bien
ce qu'il veut et donc la tour venir en
décape attaquer ses quatre attaquer F4
3 tours C4 3D 3 tours à 4 ou C3 et c'est
tout misé sur le Pione
on voit la hikao qui commence à
désespérer donc il va essayer de troquer
le pion c'est contre le pion a la tour
qui avance
quand c'est 4 arrive le foussette aussi
c'est réactive ça a l'air d'être perdu
maintenant EAO qui souffle
il calcule pas bien
dans cette partie
le pion qui arrive en C4 tour à 7 à 5 il
essaye d'envoyer le va-tout mais il sera
pas éliminé du tournoi là il est il est
dégoûté de sa partie et de sa
performance
mais il ne sera pas éliminé Ikaru il se
reviendra demain contre les perdants
pour revenir dans le tournoi des
gagnants
qui n'a pas ici
de gagner tu as juste ces pièces car ou
quand même qui est encore un micro
espoir
7 il va essayer de s'approcher
recette échec pour le plaisir
il propose du il accepte de
s'inclinera une journée de repos demain
et une deuxième vie en finale que ce
soit Hikaru ou un autre Magnus Carlsen
aura encore la possibilité de perdre un
match pour s'imposer dans dans ce
tournoi en tout cas impressionnante
performance du joueur norvégien qui
avait quand même dominé au point ce
match Fab notamment les deux premières
parties